- Maybe you've seen this warning lately.
It's not good, especially
for your phone's battery.
And...
But how hot is too hot?
Action.
There was only one way to find out.
Put some phones under a
food heat lamp, of course.
And 137 degrees.
And there's the screen.
Please do not do this at
home for many reasons,
but mainly, heat is really
bad for your phone's battery.
And well, you may have heard.
- You know, the heat is not backing off.
- And that heat is not going away.
- Heat.
- And combine that environmental heat
with processor intensive tasks
and even fast charging
and the phone temps
are only going to rise.
So why do batteries hate heat?
And what temperature triggers the warning?
And is there anything you can do about it?
And is having a mini phone fan cool?
All right, let's heat up some phones
and answer those questions.
Okay, first thing to answer,
why is heat so bad for batteries?
This is a lithium ion battery
from inside an iPhone.
I'll spare you the chemistry class,
but there's a complicated
chemical reaction
that occurs during
charging and discharging.
As you increase the temperature,
the speed of that chemical
reaction also increases,
that can cause the battery to drain faster
and the actual battery components
and capacity to degrade over time.
You can check the status of your iPhone
or Android phone's battery
capacity under settings.
But how hot is too hot
for a smartphone battery?
95 degrees seems to be the magic number
according to Apple and Android
phone makers like Samsung.
Apple specifically says here
that exposing your device
to ambient temperatures higher
than 95 degrees Fahrenheit
can permanently damage battery capacity.
But that doesn't mean your
smartphone will warn you
about overheating at 95 degrees.
I decided to test it myself
by putting this iPhone 13 Pro
and Samsung Galaxy S23
Ultra under a heat lamp.
I took the temperature readings
with this FLIR thermal camera
and an external thermometer as a backup.
The first test was just the
phone under the fake sun.
The alert popped up on the iPhone
after baking for seven
minutes and 20 seconds,
just as the front of
the phone's temperature
hit 137 degrees.
On the Samsung, an alert
popped up at the phone
was too warm about seven minutes
in when it was 128 degrees.
But unlike Apple's warning,
Samsung's doesn't limit
you from using the phone.
It just limits usage of
some parts of the device.
The second test, I wanted to know
if fast charging which
generates heat on its own
would make the temperature rise faster.
So I ran the experiment while
the phones were charging
with this special cord that
shows the charging speed.
With both the iPhone and the Samsung,
the phones just slowed the charging speed
as they got warmer.
Oh wait, now it's going
down the charging speed.
Both phones had their alerts pop up
around the same temperature,
between 130 to 135 degrees.
Ow, very hot.
Very, very hot.
And then there was the final test,
recording some video
while under the hot sun.
This really sped up the heat
because recording video is a
very processor intensive task.
The phone is at about 135 degrees,
and with the video playing,
it happened in under five minutes.
So what can you do about all this?
Well, don't put your
phone under a heat lamp,
but sometimes heat happens.
So here are some ideas that I tested.
Number one, buy a bag.
I bought this $19 thermal bag on Amazon.
I put the phones in it
and then put it under the light and...
- [Colleague] Oh, no, it's smoking.
- Okay, yeah, it is, it is.
The thermal bag hit 302 degrees
and we thought, "Let's stop this."
The phone totally cool, totally
fine inside the thermal bag.
The maker of the bag, a
company called WALLFID
did not respond to my request for comment.
I did try this $30 bag
from a company called
PHOOZY a few days later
and it didn't smoke and
it kept the phone cool.
So yeah, I'd go with that one.
Number two, limit fast charging and cases.
Apple and Android phone
makers use software
to balance fast charging
with battery longevity.
And honestly, I'd say the
convenience of charging fast
is better than babying your battery.
But if you want to slow down,
go back to this tiny charging
cube if you have an iPhone.
Samsung lets you turn off
fast charging in settings.
Apple also suggests removing phone cases
since they can generate
excess heat as well.
Some Android phones are designed
to better handle fast charging though.
This OnePlus 10T has
a vapor cooling system
so it can charge from zero
to 100% in 20 minutes.
Number three, try a fan.
Obviously, that bag doesn't work
if you wanna use your phone.
So I tried Razer's $60 phone cooler chroma
which attaches back here.
The only problem with it
is that the fan itself
needs to be plugged in.
Still, I was blown away at
how cool it kept the phone.
No temperature warning on this side.
It has been under the
lamp for about 10 minutes.
Look, the good news is
battery damage isn't gonna just happen
from that one time you left
the phone on the beach,
but your battery is
gonna degrade over time
and heat will only speed that up.
So stay...
There's only one place
you're going with this phone.
It's not a rave, it's a land party.